[Music]
here it is kids ever wonder and what
does it look like what is the face of 49
this zip fraught with peril
on a dog walk less a dog walk more dog
drag Shecky in full effect even to turn
this around look at her all pissed and
vinegar old as the hills 14 and still
she just wants to go go go till we get
to her onion then she shuts down it
starts acting like a little dick alright
man here it is 49 day one of 49 last day
in my 40s next year on this day God
willing if I'm still around my heart
hasn't come back and attacked me I think
I'm gonna do a show at Carnegie Hall
like I did years back like 10 years ago
so yeah that'll be [ __ ] wicked this
year no show on my birthday but I'm
going to Jersey to do some live readings
of the clerks three script to benefit
First Avenue playoffs in Atlantic
Highlands so that's nice but today today
I start the last year of my 40s trying
not to die yet again [ __ ] hiking
Runyon Canyon wearing a Mallrats shirt
even though we got J and sambar reboot
coming out in October on the 25th
anniversary of clerks next year 2020 is
the 25th
all right yes 25th anniversary of
Mallrats
so expect some announcements there
but in any event what do I feel like at
49
well almost died at 47 so this rocks
still here would have been a weird two
years if I've been dead probably
wouldn't have gotten to make Jane
ssambap reboot you know I said probably
because special effects meant they could
do anything I watch The Avengers like
four times so far since this [ __ ]
streaming and they make Michael Douglas
look like a [ __ ] kid younger than he
looked in the China Syndrome so if they
could do that they probably could have
made reboot without my dead fat ass but
mercifully I'm here we didn't have to do
that the what else has happened in that
time I don't know it was a packed year
and changed since that heart attack and
the last you know birthday was all like
woohoo I survived the heart attack so
the whole last year has just been packed
I kind of live now like you know I'm
waiting for the other shoe to drop
living on borrowed time all this shit's
borrowed time playing on house money
borrowing other metaphors as well so
[ __ ] it back that way
not you know in as much as like I have
no regard for human [ __ ] life
obviously I do probably much more regard
for human life than ever had before
which is saying a lot because I always
had a lot of regard for human life but
yeah don't act out in ways like that if
you feel like you're living on borrowed
time make some [ __ ] don't break some
[ __ ] anybody can break some [ __ ] make
some [ __ ] man like make an impact on the
world and don't make I'm gonna make
carnage that's not making something
that's breaking something make something
make a bunch of [ __ ] make stupid [ __ ]
Jay Saleh Bob reboot is wonderful but
you know nobody asked for it
of me
and I mean that's pretty much true of
everything I've ever made but now having
like lived through the art Zach and
don't start slowing down we have miles
to go before we sleep this is where she
starts going are we done
I'm [ __ ] him running Canyon yet [ __ ]
and when I say [ __ ] she is a like
female dog so but I don't always call it
that and kids don't use that term all
right ha ha
speaking of shaggy still doing good
folks have been asking what hey what do
we get you for your birthday you don't
have to give me anything man I'm good I
you know as my wife laments all the time
he just gives everything he wants to get
for himself and he never leaves anything
for the rest of us to get but the older
I get I don't want that much you know I
just long for the [ __ ] of childhood
finding like [ __ ] toys I used to have
anything that reminds me of being a kid
on 21 Jackson Street that's that's cool
but ice hunt that stuff down myself so
there's really nothing anyone needs to
get me but if you're hard-pressed and
you're like god damn it it's not a
birthday unless I give you something
gift
go to reboot Roadshow come pick up your
tickets for the J and some about reboot
Roadshow tour or go to Fatima vent and
pick up your tickets for the fathom
screenings band along October 17th is a
double feature strike back and reboot
I'll be a lovely birthday gift all right
let me see 49 when I was a kid I was
born in 1970 so I loved an Avengers end
game when they show that big fat New
Jersey 1970 card I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm
finally I'm unborn born apparently the
same years Tony Stark but when I was a
kid since I was born 70 and my math was
like real basic I would just be like oh
my god
in the year 2000 I'm gonna be 30 years
old that's so [ __ ] old and today I'm
49
19 years past what I once believed to be
the oldest mark in the world probably a
biblical old age 30 and on this modern
era so in one way you look at it I'm
living way past living on much more
borrowed time
you know Oh keV who was young keV who is
really [ __ ] young keV I thought we'd
make it a 30 max I don't know how much
longer I got you know keep taking care
of the ticker I'm a Weight Watchers
ambassador that absolutely helps go see
my doctor cardiologist dr. Leighton Heim
this week for my checkup but so far so
good but regardless feel like I'm
certainly not done but if they were like
you're done I'd be like I get it I don't
enough while I'm still here we keep
doing keep making weird [ __ ]
keep him using myself
trying to lose you oh all right where
the mouth man
the mouth of ronnied Union 49 begins
right now
feeling the effects yep
feeling old everyone around me as young
bunch of youngsters I like I know why
I'm here
I'll have a traditional job but
apparently nobody in Los Angeles hazard
additional jobs everybody got time to go
hiking Runyon that's why we like it out
here
suppose you're slackers I'm checking out
shaggy
she'll crap out probably as soon as we
hit the big incline I'm with her man oh
I just uh uh uh uh come on
if you want we'll sit here for a sec
here there's where Shecky is in the
world I know what you're doing you're
killing time you are killing time
[ __ ] the canyon awaits it's not
gonna come to us we got to go to it
come on she's like but can we go this
way we're gonna go this way my friend
it's time please don't be running into
people this is your sound seam douchiest
[ __ ] but I could put sunglasses on
because it's about to get very bright
and interesting factoid after years of
opening my eyes as wide as I [ __ ]
Canon photos and in movies I'm a little
light-sensitive go figure there are
moments in reboot where I'm like trying
to have my eyes real wide and like
there's too much Sun and too much light
being thrown at us in the movie and you
can see it's like a [ __ ] struggle
that's old age um all right birthday
wisdom to all the stupid [ __ ] you want
to do as long as it doesn't hurt anybody
kids so that's really nice
tweet somebody put up a screen shot of a
reddit thread were I guess they asked
people ever thought about killing
themselves and what stopped them and
somebody was saying that some episode of
spot guess that we did years ago we're
talking about Aquaman getting hot with
Aquaman underwater stop my man um dogs
lots and lots of dogs stop my man from
taking the step off a subway platform
that was profoundly moving to read but
also just a big reminder that sit around
and dream with your friends sit around
dream with your friends do goofy [ __ ]
talk about goofy [ __ ] even if people I
guess a waste of time nobody knows
apparently wasn't a waste of time
apparently that goofy conversation about
Aquaman made a difference for somebody
hopefully ask somebody's still kicking
around hopefully we'll meet one day but
nobody writes your story but you a lot
of people will tell you some [ __ ] you're
doing is dope dope II don't listen what
you do is you build a chapel slowly it
takes shape becomes larger Church and
one day you realize it's a cathedral and
as your spire breaks the clouds they're
still always gonna be somebody they're
telling you how you're doing it wrong
never listen unless it saved your life
if somebody's like move then you know
listen cuz probably something's about to
fall on you but if they're like you know
you shouldn't do it like that do what's
right for you
Kaiser boy there's somebody on my screen
comment threat talking about like reboot
and they're like hey man aren't you
gonna release this movie in a normal
theatrical release which is you know I
guess what movies with budgets get I had
to explain we have a ten million dollar
budget in order to open a movie wide
theatrically you'd need another 20
million case-in-point and Luke comedy
like the long shot and just using a
comedy that's just came out this summer
minimum ad spend his Lionsgate was 20
million and so that means whatever the
movie costs
gets totaled together and that's what
you will and that adds spent ain't
guaranteed to make a single person show
up so our movie costs 10 million to
release it in a quote-unquote normal
theatrical release with 20 million bucks
don't fight
that's that means you got to make back
30 million all of a sudden and then in
order to do that you don't get the
box-office report reported figures so if
they like this movie grossed 100 million
the studio people make the movie they
only walk away at 50 you guys split the
money with the exhibitors people in the
theaters right so at that point in order
for don't fight James Samba reboot to
earn back its 30 million dollars I'd
have to make 60 million at the box
office and no movie I've ever made has
ever made 60 million at the box office
so does that mean that one can't play no
you know look just because people got
money don't mean they're the only ones
get to do fun [ __ ] we don't have enough
money to sell the movie we got enough
money to make the money so we got to be
more clever with the sell of the movie
so that's what we're doing man
combining all the things we know how to
do its maximize the life of the movie
profits in the movie without spending to
do so you know anybody can spend twenty
million dollars on a movie to make
people notice it and doesn't always
guaranteed to work it's not always
guaranteed to work but you know if
you're clever and if you've built leg
and all along a tail big audience like
we have over the quarter last quarter of
a century you could be more amenable so
for everybody that wants to see it like
just has a in quote unquote normal the
Curly's in a movie theater October 15th
and 17th BAM we got you covered with
sneak preview screenings from fathom
events that October 19th the Jay and
Silent Bob reboot Roadshow tour begins
that's where we and Jay go
state-to-state City City with the movie
show you the movie do show afterwards
that's what I'm looking forward to
because I want to see the movie with
people that love it that's why I make
these things for you and then for the
people that get into him so normally
when you released a movie fiasco life a
movie about a month - if you're lucky
this will be completely different I
could stretch the life of the movie as
long as I want at that point so first
leg of the reboot Roadshow tour goes
from October to late December then after
Christmas I go back out from January to
March getting all the places that aren't
there yet all Canadian dates and whatnot
so that's five months longer than most
movies get in a theatrical life and then
you know they're on home video will be
there - eventually almost rest your [ __ ]
out and I don't want to spend twenty
million dollars to salve my ego to do it
to be like oh we got TV spots like not
for nothing but I don't even know if
anybody watches TV anymore you know
tables tilted kids but it doesn't mean
you can't tilt it back in your favor
it's part of the fun yeah it's fun
making the movie but for us it's fun
selling the movie as well getting the
movie out there you know try to use
everything we ever learned well and do
it in an interesting way hang out with
the fans I don't know seems to make
sense for me and then come on [ __ ] if
you don't catch it on the tour if you're
like I don't want to pay 50 bucks to
watch a movie with you and Jay
even though people pay 50 bucks to watch
me and Jay talk to each other without a
movie that's why we knew the audience
would dig this but let's say you're not
into that well then after the movie
opens and you're the reboot roadshows
two-hour opens in your neck of the woods
like say October 20th we're in Chicago
then that weekend reboot opens in
theaters in Chicago its platform release
it's the world that came from it's how
clerks came out clerks been playing a
bunch of screens never play it on more
than 50 screens at once there's platform
release open this city open that city
make sure it's working so same thing
here but we have the benefit of knowing
it's working events cuz we've sold out a
bunch of shows and added more so you
done you good with the water so so far
so good you know now for the cat who
asked the question was like hey your
thing don't make sense to me well good
news is I know that cat any money I
don't have to justify oh come on Carmen
no dog fighting come I don't have to
justify how we're doing things Tim go
come on
uh-huh go you are not fighting with any
dogs go go come in so here it is that's
my thoughts on the subject not just the
subject of my movie but you got to live
your life the way you want to live your
life where's Randall said and clerks too
you gotta live your life the way you
live your life for you yeah [ __ ] ass
and that's what I'm doing at age 49
living life as best I can
for me all right we're almost at the
point of Runyon where we lose power
signal let's check on Shecky
schecky oh yeah they're in little legs
man I wish I had four all right kids
up I go happy belated birthday - Ming
Chen comic book men's Ming Chen whose
birthday was yesterday
happy current birthday said not just me
but my brother Donnell
it's his birthday too I was born on his
birthday four years after he was born
dog party um no you cannot fight those
stuffs coming
he was August 2nd 1966 how does August
2nd 97 of fighting know all right kids
come on stop trying to [ __ ] fight
it's my goddamn birthday be a peace at
peace not every dog is your [ __ ]
enemy in fact the way I see no dogs are
your [ __ ] enemy so knock it off
you're embarrassing me being all [ __ ]
German and [ __ ] say to your Hill there
it is kids sorry about the lecture
sometimes me shaky get the [ __ ] into it
so happy birthday to my brother done
whose birthday I kind of co-opted in
stole um there it is folks go out today
okay you're my con man who you ain't got
b49
start thinking about you know not dying
speaking of got far with you
that's a hike can I check almost at the
bench no fighting dogs well we should
start some [ __ ] all right man there it
is
thanks for hanging out thanks for all
the birthday greetings I love you all
see you on the reboot Roadshow